CBS has this report actor Will Smith
says that he would understand if
audiences are not ready to see him on
the big screen so soon after the
infamous Oscar slap earlier this year on
Monday Smith spoke to Fox 5 DC's Kevin
McCarthy about his new film emancipation
which is set to be released in theaters
in December 2nd and starts streaming on
Apple TV on December 9th uh it's his
first major project since he slapped
Chris Rock on stage at the Academy
Awards and this is a movie as the title
suggests it's a movie about
slavery emancipation centers around
Smith's character Peter Peter an
enslaved man who escapes a Louisiana
Plantation and makes his way North the
film was inspired by 1863 photos of a
man whose bareback was mutilated from
whippings by his enslavers
well even before we talk about Will
Smith specifically I will say that I'm
just I'm glad we finally have a movie
about slavery
um and finally finally
Hollywood is telling this story
um I because I think the story has never
been told and we have we haven't heard
about this and uh it's just really good
I mean at the very least it had been 17
seconds since the last Slavery movie and
uh we know that if if we're gonna if
there's gonna be a movie about American
history
like as far as Hollywood's concerned
this is the only thing that happened in
American history
uh only certainly the only thing that
you can tell a story about
so that's great uh but Will Smith is
kind of on this on this publicity tour
and where he's he's claiming that I
don't care you don't it's if you if I
understand if you don't if you're still
upset and he's pretending to be
apologetic but then if you listen to
what he's saying
it actually doesn't sound very
apologetic to me here he is with uh
Trevor Noah a couple nights ago listen
I guess what I would say
you just never know what somebody's
going through
you know you know in in the audience
right now you know you're sitting next
to uh strangers you know and
somebody's mother died last week you
know
um somebody's child is sick
you know
um somebody just lost their job
somebody just found out their spouse
cheated you know there's it's like
there's all these things and these
there's strangers and you just don't
know
what's going on with people you know and
there's I was going through something
that night you know and uh not that that
you know justifies my behavior at all I
would just say and you know you're
asking what did I learn and it's that
um
we just got to be nice to each other man
you know it's like it's hard
I'm not justifying or excusing my
behavior
but here's my justification and my
excuse I was going through something so
this is really what he's doing he's he's
like really Will Smith is doing the
victim routine and he's making and if
you listen to him he's just making a
whole bunch of excuses I I don't even
think that he's that he's actually
apologetic at all
um
because if you're actually apologetic
you're not going to get into this I was
going through something no one gives a
damn what you were going through you got
up what you did was so
unbelievable it's like it goes beyond
inappropriate it doesn't begin to cover
it okay
and yes is it was it worth the all the
headlines everything no nothing is ever
worth all the the attention the media
gives to it but at the same time it's
still uh the kind of thing that yeah
that's gonna destroy your career now
look look at this one
because there is now this uh
this move online it's like this actually
seems to me anecdotally there's a lot of
sympathy for for Will Smith and people
say well we should forgive him and he's
one of these putting him in the category
of these canceled he's a bit he's been
canceled
no this is not actually being canceled
this this in fact is just this really is
just a natural consequence for your
actions like getting banned from the
Academy Awards well you physically you
committed assault in the middle of the
ceremony of course they're going to get
banned that would happen to anybody so
just imagine if you were like what if
you were at your job and it's it's it
and you have some kind of banquet at
your job maybe an awards you know they
said like some kind of awards banquet at
your job and they're awarding employee
of the year and all these kind of things
and they bring someone up in the MC at
this uh banquet
and he makes a mild joke about you or
about your wife or something and you get
up
and you physically assault the guy in
front of all your co-workers at this
employee banquet
would would you even bother begging for
your job back
like he would sit down and know okay
well I'm getting fired for that and I'm
also going to go to jail by the way
because that's a felony assault that I
just committed
and that would happen to anybody
and any normal person
so the fact that anyone's even talking
about like accepting Will Smith back
into the fold that's just privilege that
no one else would get
if that was you you're done you're fired
you're not getting another job either
when people find out about that and also
again you you are going to be criminally
prosecuted for it which he never was
so no I actually don't think that I'm
all about people make mistakes and I'm
100 against cancel culture but there is
you know not everything is cancel
culture sometimes someone just acts out
this is physical assault you committed
in the middle uh
and and sometimes it really just is a
consequence of that and that'll do it
for this portion of the shows and move
over to the members blog hope to see you
there if not talk to you tomorrow
Godspeed
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]